ladies and gentlemen would you mind
please remaining on your feet while we
have a minute silence in view of the
activities in London today thank you
very much
every
good evening members and officers of the
council and members of the press and
public I welcome you to this meeting of
the council if the fire alarm is
activated please vacate the offices by
the stairs through the security doors to
my right or opposite the lists in the
foyer do not use the lifts but please
assembly in holy square on the green the
officers will assist you and advise you
when it seems safe to return to the
chamber the Proceedings of this meeting
will be recorded and subsequently
broadcast on the internet I would advise
to the filming takes place anyone in
attendance in the public areas may have
their image capture so I urge anyone
filming proceedings to avoid filming
members of the public particularly if
there are children present does anyone
intend to film the proceedings thank you
very much if any member of the public
objects to the possibility of being
filmed you may wish to take this
opportunity to leave any filming or
recording will not be permitted for any
item of business where exempt or
confidential information is considered
following the exclusion of the press and
the public from the meetings would
everyone present please ensure their
mobile phones are turned to silent and
that they are not used to make or
receive phone calls in the chamber
whilst this meeting is in progress Thank
You agenda item number 1 apologies for
absence I have apologies from councillor
Glenn Coleman cook and councillor iris
Johnson are there any other apologies
please
thank you yes Carthage ages thank you
thank you very much gender item number
two the minutes of the previous meeting
I move that the minutes of the meeting
of council held on the 20 soda februari
2017 be approved and signed as a correct
record with the vice chairman three
seconds secondly do members agree thank
you gender item number three I have not
been informed of any announcements
agenda item number four are there any
declarations of interest can you advise
me obvious the house of eyes sorry I put
a pardon whether or not the disbandment
of this council that the of do need to
declare an interest no no you do not
need to be an angel no that's not
tonight's decision thank you agenda item
number five then the business case for
the single East Kent Council I'd like to
allow a full and comprehensive debate of
this important item if members wish to
do so however I would politely ask
members to try and avoid repetition when
addressing the chamber during the course
of the debate I call then upon the
leader councillor wealth Oh Castle Baker
I'm sure it's almost just indicating I'd
like to speak when if you don't begin
with you oh I'm very I'm very happy with
the way the procedures are going so far
thank you
well thank you very much thank you this
young the I'm going to be a very brief
in institution is item I just want to to
make three or four very simple points
and then sit back and listen to what are
the debate may followers clearly we have
some very eager participants to come the
in July last year this council in
concert with before other councils at
that time put forward proposals they
want to actually research a business
case with an independent consultant in
order to see whether or not a sensible
merger of applied councils could put
together as you will know your poor to
this council back in January this year
that business case was published and
below times was published we had gone
from five to four councils and those
four councils are all meeting tonight to
look at the next stage of this process
because in those recommendations that we
passed in July last year it did say
quite simply if the business case
demonstrates that there appeared to be
positive benefits that could result for
all of those four councils we would then
look at a meeting in March of this year
in order to actually move it forward for
discussion with the public when you call
that a consultation a public engagement
whatever it may be we have all had the
opportunity to look at the business case
see what the benefits arguably our or
ask we have all had the opportunity to
sit through briefings on this subject
both in small group and in large group
formats and you've all had the
opportunity to read all said before or
so pages of business case and I hope the
kissing grades upon your heart yes no
okay we are in constant tonight we're
three other councils looking at moving
this forward to having consultation to
start hopefully tomorrow for a period of
some weeks in order to actually ask the
public want to think about this case in
principle now the business case has come
forward saying they would appear to be
benefits in moving
that particular direction there are four
recommendation tonight those four
recommendations include approval for
bending the excess money for the
extremely good deal we actually got in
terms of producing that business case
because was all a lot less than we
actually expected in order to pay for
that consultation as it moves forward
they include all of the recommendations
that were put forward form of the
scrutiny panel when they looked at this
particular subject or in between the
Cabinet decision to move ahead for
public consultation and the decision of
this council here tonight and say I look
forward to hearing what send any base
and hope and trust at the end of this
evenings debate we will in concert with
three other councils move forward to
examine closely with the public the next
stage in this particular journey thank
you thank you guys for well to have a
seconder please I'd like to second in
reserve the right play
careful beta yeah Thank You chairman
first of all I think I should make it
clear that the conservative group has a
free vote on this item tonight there are
a shade of opinion about where we might
be going and I think that it's only
right that people should exercise that
that right to actually say what they
think in representation of the
electorate that I serve I think
therefore i need to make it very clear
that what I've got to save my view not
group view it's my view and I think that
the point that the leaders made is very
important to remember that this is
merely moving us on to the next stage
there will be consultation the outcome
of that we don't know what that will be
what I'm sure though is that the final
shape of the new authority may not look
like the business case suggests there's
got to be lots and lots of discussion
there will be lots of argument about the
way things should work and I also
believe that I know some some members
think that there are alternatives that
we're not discussing that we should
things like more shared services unitary
which I know is the terrible word that
we're not supposed to use but you know
it's in the back of people's minds and
i'm sure that at the end of the day if
that becomes the right course of action
for East Kent that may be the way we'll
go but what I do think is vital that
we've got to do something you know the
fact is that if we just do nothing right
now we just sit here and we wait
effectively for the bailiffs to turn up
now the money's getting tighter it will
get more time there's no doubt about
that at the moment I think that this
council in particular is doing very well
and maintaining services but that can't
go on forever eventually services will
be impacted upon and I don't want to sit
and wait for that to happen I think we
need to do something um I think that the
proposal we've got is actually something
new if it comes about it will be the
largest second tier authority in the
country
and I think that that gives us lots of
opportunity to create something new and
beneficial to the residents of planet
I've said before I say again that a nice
can't super dispute or whatever we are
going to be allowed to call it probably
will be able to take on some of the
responsibilities of County equally it
will be possible to pass down to towns
and parishes some services that they
perhaps can deliver more effectively
locally I think the democratic process
will be served by that and I think we
should do it I'm running out of time I
just think will please continue
counselor blonde I'm not register that I
mean but that was that was nice get out
because I did say a full and thorough
debate so I'm going to be a bit generous
with the time I particularly for group
leaders even though you're expressing
your emotions that the fact is that you
know really i think the point is made
either i don't know what the shape of
local government will look like but it's
got to be different and I think we've
got to start now if we don't do it now
how long is it going to be before we do
start another couple of years another
couple of years and one of the things
that I think is really scary is that if
we don't take control of our own destiny
someone else will the government will
step in and save burgos Israel whatever
and I don't want us to do that I believe
it's the right thing for the residents
of planet and i would ask everybody in
this chamber to recognize me she's just
going to the next step and i think we
owe it to the people of st. so just that
thank you very much thank you very much
councilor Ken Gregory people Thank You
chairman just to prove the hair group is
not weird i'm going to say almost
exactly the opposite what this motion or
this proposal has done has in solve
something that's been rolling on for the
last 44 years and that is that some
people now want to keep planning
district council and 44 years ago they
didn't want the thing to be here so in
the last six months we've done something
but more importantly the business plan
for this proposed proposed merger is
there
weak very weak indeed and I know it's
been tabled that's not what's going to
happen so why'd we got it in front of us
it should be a proper business plan
rather than something that speculative
and probably inaccurate then we've got
the financial savings of getting read as
they say a lot of chiefs and keeping
more Indians if you're allowed to say
Indians but in actual fact as we know if
you build an aircraft carrier it doubles
in price if you project ten percent
savings you might get two percent
because that goes in the inverse way and
so really I don't think we can rely on
the savings I agree we have to change
sanuk District Council on its own
Canterbury doverton shepway will not
survive but there are other options out
there I know we're not discussing those
options tonight but we have an
opportunity tonight to turn round and
actually say enough's enough we need to
explore all the options rather than just
one when I make a decision I like that
decision to actually be based on the
information available not just on the
information available and what's before
us but the information that's available
in the real world so that we can look at
it and say well this actually isn't a
good idea so far we've had an option
place before us by full chief executives
and four officers member leaders rather
and the result of that is that
everything else hasn't been put before
us and we really do need to have stuff
put before us so that we make a valued
decision I we need to make a decision
but the comments being made well we're
not actually deciding to do it tonight
we're going to move it forward to public
public consultation and that right up
until the final council meeting where we
finally discuss it we have the
opportunity to throw it away my fear is
we're being herded like cattle into a
corner and there's only one gate out I
prefer to our four gates so if you get
out the way that I really wanted to
because I know what will happen we'll
get to the top of the staircase and
decide we want to come back down we turn
around and ochre the steps are
disappeared and I think this is the
wrong way to be doing it it needs more
thought it's hurried it's rushed the
time scale is totally inappropriate and
to say that we have
or we could perhaps go on for another
year well I don't even think another
years the right thing we've got to get a
move on and I suggest now we should be
getting a move on it actually looking
for alternatives and then making a valid
decision thank you okay I what I would
like to do here is I would like to amend
the recommendations I'd like that to be
amended in the following way that this
council gives the residents the
opportunity to voice their opinions via
referendum why do I call for a
referendum well I think it would be fair
I think it would be a fair way of
dealing with the residents of the town
think it refers to all give them the
opportunity to express their views and
to have those views properly and fully
taken into consideration which so far
hasn't occurred now I appreciate that
that would be a cost it would be a cost
but I think that's the cost worth pain
to get the residence property involved I
think it's about time that we really
knew what the people of ramsgate sink
and we really understood what the people
of ramsgate Sally sorry I do correct
myself I remember the people have
families all the families including
ramsgate I think it is time that we
fully understood what they want and what
their views are on this matter thank you
thank you can't forecast taken just for
clarity please are you by your Amendment
seeking to add an additional or are you
seeking to change for example number
three could you write the amendment down
please yes cool thank you
understand how does each other shows
the council college I just one more
question please just just for clarity
are you proposing in your amendment that
this referendum replaces the current
plan to consult or that it comes at some
point later I think it needs to come at
some point later later no sorry can I
just be guided by my colleagues actually
a new cell instead on the proposed right
thank you that I'll thank um would you
like to I'm going to ask the chief
executive to say a few words before can
we just hear what the amendment actually
eat at some stage perhaps even before
any of us comment on it the amendment is
as follows brought by council of
constance I and the seconded by
Councillor matter face that this council
gives the residents of Senate the
opportunity to voice their opinions via
a referendum chief executive please
Thank You chairman I'm clearly just make
sure that you're aware there any such
agreement for this amendment would have
to be subject to budget considerations
and confirmation from my other three
district colleagues who also involved in
this process so whatever amendment you
agree this evening would have to be
subject to both of those points
I just clarify so because this is part
of the budget policy framework this
would then go back to cabinet initially
for them to review the changes yes
so we have an amendment before us with
any members like to comment on the
substance of the amendment character
wealth all right councillor Adams please
yes sir I would come in my comment would
be it's too early to talk about
referendums because we haven't got all
the fine detail yet about this merger
because we haven't even agreed to go
consultation yet so why would those
members to vote against it thank you
can't reverse because I think the point
about this is you know the referendum is
that is a nice sounding vehicle to play
with and it's a great headline and
tweaked beautifully but the bottom line
is where they're talking about a budget
commitment across the four counts of the
whole of probably somewhere in the
region of three for three hundred fifty
thousand pounds don't have to be put
together and operated that will take a
period of time where this was been
suggested in lincolnshire recently was
rejected purely on the grounds of course
as well as the time related to it and I
i think the end of the final decision is
not due to come before us and the
earliest until July or maybe not until
this autumn the guidance in the
consultation is proposed would give us a
very strong sphere on to how strongly
people do actually feel and could then
decide whether or not we need to
referendum in due course we've already
been urged by my colleague over here
that we are taking this too rushed that
actually you want something done
straight away so I mean I go with this
degree of confusion at the approach to
this which I find quite interesting I'm
told in one sense that this is
speculative and inaccurate information
and another sense we're told now we have
to go for a binary yes-or-no decision
where everybody is going to be operated
on presumably expectancy than in a
ferret information so I do think the
consultation process is proposed which
you've all had a briefing on gives a
selection of residence the ability to
look at this in some detail that's a
more sensible way forward
and it's certainly one that doesn't
actually then involve having to go find
yet more money to spend on something in
our budget which has been tough enough
today and also trying to bring three
other colleagues with us who may have an
entirely different view the view thing
out before you is wander actually in
terms of consultation has been generally
agreed by all four councils and as such
is the best one to move forward with
right now so on those grounds i would
urge council please to reject this
amendment and move back to the main
proposal Thank You counsel Campbell yes
I do chair just an observation really
eyes I'm rather confused i like the you
keep leader new keep members or attic
against referendum RT talked early be
all in favor I mean they were certainly
William favor a referendum but took
place on another nationally on another
issue some time ago I thought maybe all
in favor referendum and the result of
those referendum and had confidence that
leaders a referendum would go the way
that they did you let you wish them to
go just a lot of devotion as I say but I
do think it's appropriate we are looking
this process that's actually the demise
of the local government for Senate
individually don't the residents of
panic to deserve the opportunity to have
their views heard you know in a
referendum I think they do thank you
cancelled later please well I think
Thank You Sherman I mean I think
everybody knows that when y'all'd a
referendum you often get the wrong
result but we don't want we don't want
to do any of that but seriously that's
quite seriously leaders right I mean if
you have a referendum it's got to be a
binary question has me what's that
question going to be because I would
argue that if you ask all of the
counselors here tonight to write down
what they think the new counter is going
to look like it get 56 different views
so what are you going to ask the
residents expand it to say whether they
like or don't like I mean it's just
totally impractical I'm sorry I think
two-bit the daft idea sorry Thank You
cancer adversely
and would it be possible that all the
involve councils sort of get invited to
the winter gardens and they had a big
conference about it for one day and see
what the general feeling is around the
whole area instead of just us thank you
stick that I i think that the purpose
the consultation all four councils the
the one of the things that got rejected
earlier is the idea that we'd actually
have other words an idea earlier on that
we'd actually have all of these fifteen
campuses come together to form the new
council i did say i did think that
putting 213 district councillors in one
room would be a recipe for disaster that
is exactly conservative i say what is
happening tonight we have four councils
who are looking to move forward
consultant with their own residents in
their own way but in a consistent manner
across the four councils that's what
we're headed towards that's what you're
asked to approve and i'm quite sure if i
propose if you do it the winter gardens
like a funny feeling somebody else might
mention that these get all my apologies
sir I just wanted to move with honor
just one of it was possible for us to
vote on the amendment now thank you very
much I've checked my list everybody who
indicated they wanted to speak has done
so so proposed by a counselor Karen
Constantine seconded by council general
matter face the amendment reads that
this council gives the residents of San
at the opportunity to voice their
opinions via a referendum which is
instead of the process that's been laid
before us so far so please may I have a
show of hands those in favor of adopting
the amendment
you
thank you those against please thank you
very much thank you very much the
amendment fails we return them to the
substantive Catholic seminars I to note
that i abstained on that one thank you
to the motion and cancel hate completion
thank you very much German evolved
government this is the kind of devolved
government but it's hidden it would be
dissolved because other district
councils will want to go as well I've
read the whole article right way through
not once but twice and I believe that
came bravery sense of great 10 Gregory
is quite great I think it doesn't go
sour mash I want to see devolution down
to parishes and ten councils people who
know their towns and parishes better
than we do better than we do in this
chamber and quite frankly what they what
this is happening is your devolved in
this power and authority to Canterbury
because every time I read something in
that document it is Canterbury
Canterbury will shed all their problems
our way somebody asked that the overview
and scrutiny committee the other night
what this means construction what that
meant is building houses and houses and
/ Canterbury people to live in because
we are shedding a lot of businesses up
to Canterbury they don't want us they
want the property that will withstand on
and living in and quite frankly i'd like
to see devolved situations down to the
lowest denomination as I said before
parishes and Pam councils because as I
said before they know what is in late
well the business of running a council
locally is chairman I will not be
supporting anything on this but
proposition thank you seguin dr. wells
you see yeah i agree that the business
case does not contain it i right deal
about that but the members briefings and
the discussions to a place around the
members briefings and another
conversation certainly has
I gave a speech on behalf of the forest
councils that are conference in
maidstone on the tractor debris which
made it quite clear that devolution to
parishes and we have twenty-five percent
of the patient's again in that room that
day the devolution parishes is an
inevitability and a certainty of this
particular change because there are bits
bits and pieces of what we do we're
actually the local touch of the people
who when they step outside their front
door and see what they want to do with
their Park and the opening as their
toilets and all those sorts of things
are fundamental and are part of the
immediate parts of local life they will
even be a proposal contained within
there eventually my way actually with a
certain amount of planning requirements
go down to parish and town councils as
well and that's already been done in
Windsor so there is a legal way of
actually doing it so Dima Lucien two
parishes is very much part of this and
it's something that we involved with the
Kent Association local councils and
explaining in some detail the difficulty
of course with devolution down to parish
councils is that they have a choice
about what they want it or not and the
part that is emerging ovaries Kenda's
all is that some want to do a lot and
some want to do a little and some want
to do nothing at all and you know it's
going to be a protractor formal
negotiation to find out what
individually each parish and town
council wants to take on and we have an
additional problem of course in margate
because they're bits of Margot our
parish there are bits of Margate that
our trusty and whilst I hesitate to
comment too much on that but I'd better
not because mostly probably unprintable
the requirement is that we have the
right sort of devolved powers to
parishes and the right sort of devolved
parishes to take them on back is an
inevitability of a move like this so you
get both local skill and resilience and
strength of larger contracts Thank You
counsel Wells castle campbell yes Thank
You Jer obviously this document this
issue has been dealt with by overview
and scrutiny and there was a number of
recommendations been mentioned by ova
in the way to the cabinet quite recently
and the cabinet have agreed that there'd
be an amendment to the agenda for
decision making of this particular
project for instance in the agenda it
still states that the executive decision
by a cavity of each council to proceed
with the project to the new eastgate
council in july it was agreed by the
cabinet that that would be taken by
members members of the council for
council members also when it says in
autumn 2017 final decisions when it goes
before the DCLG yeah that's also was
agreed by cabinet to actually go to full
council to decide so tonight we are not
deciding whether or not to proceed to
this but these kids for what we are
doing is giving our residents the
opportunity for them to voice their
opinion on whether or not this project
should go forward or not now are you
seriously as representatives of your
residents going to deny them that
opportunity it's are you seriously going
to vote against giving them the
opportunity to voice their opinion I'm
erasing it is a good idea or not what my
group certainly isn't it's not width but
unanimously decided if I was certainly
not going to not to give them their
residents the opportunity to voice their
opinion indeed I already called a number
of residents meetings to aqui ask them
myself and actually told them that
there's going to be hopefully after
tonight or opportunity for them to
impart into this process it's their
local government they should have that
decision they should have their voices
should be heard all those all members
all members to vote for this tonight
cancel Martin Thank You chair may I just
echo the words of councillor Campbell
because I am extremely concerned that
there is not enough information so far
for people to make an informed vote I do
declare an interest particularly in the
powers of devolution I understand that
is not specifically relevant for this
evenings but I have to say that it is
very much relevant to me
to know exactly what decision-making
powers will dissolve if they want them
to the town council and until that is
clear on planning and capital
expenditure and development I don't
think that this is well-timed to ask
people very important that we ask but
also important that we ask the right
questions with the right information and
sufficient information thank you thank
you councillor Ashby please Thank You
chair and actually what I was going to
ask has been covered by our counselor
Campbell is to restore just a bit make
it clear page 71 five dot six we did
agree full council would replace the
words for cabinet and on the final
decision by full council so that is the
page that we're referring to it was a
recommendation from scrutiny to cabinet
which is which we believe was agreed
so yes the changes to the time saver on
page 70 as occasion 17 and 18 and then
if there is a council was a xyron the
executive
so just to clarify the annex is
unchanged because that's the original
document you can't change the annex
because that's what we're taking to the
meetings
thank you very much chairman I've been
listening very carefully to what members
have said tonight and although I have
not been a member of this Authority for
very long I have been accounts or
elsewhere and the similar situation
arose which I won't bore you with the
details it's often very hard to think of
potentially saying goodbye to an
organization that you might have been
part of for many years and I understand
a lot of people are very against change
at all but sometimes change can be very
empowering and positive and people I've
been talking to actually quite excited
about this you know there's a lot of
optimism there are potentially a lot of
good things that can have come to the
people of planet I think in the future
it's going to take an awful lot of hard
work absolutely true and the business
case that we have here the document
actually doesn't give us all the answers
and it can't at this stage as others
have said I mean it will evolve along
the process I don't think we should be
frightened though and I don't think on
behalf of the electorate that we
represent here tonight we we don't have
to tell them every detail I don't think
we can't yet I think we just have to
give them the broad perspectives that
this is actually a good thing and we
want to improve their lives and to
attract more money and all the possible
things that I hope will come should this
decision be taken tonight but I just
want to say one very brief other thing
mr. chairman but throughout this process
which I think whether it happens or not
it's been unsettling for all the
officers and staff to this council I
have said that before I just like to
repeat that we should bear in mind that
the day job has to carry on whilst all
the extra work has been taking place
behind the scenes that I personally
haven't seen any of but I know it has so
I just like to pay tribute to all the
staff the offices and continue to after
their support through this process Thank
You mr. Chen thank you very much
who would like to add comments miss
please cancel go thing is yelling well
I've listened to the debate I've with
the article and I have spoke to the
parish council and some people at public
or Minster and all I can add to this is
that Minster would welcome something on
these lines as for so many years we've
been under the iron heel or the jackboot
of sanik district council we have called
for the wilderness and the darkness and
never been heard so on behalf of the
residents of Minster that I have spoke
to on on behalf of the parish council I
welcome this and also be supporting you
thinking Thank you Thank You members for
all the contribution move to the vote so
can I please have a show of hands for
those in favor of the proposal as it is
before us
ok thank you those against please
any abstentions please thank you very
much the proposal is passed thank you
for the discussion agenda item number 6
no petitions have been received by the
council in accordance with our petition
scheme similarly agenda item number 7 no
questions have been received from the
press or members of the public in
accordance with council Procedure rule
13 gender item number eight questions
for members of the council no questions
have been received from members in
accordance with procedural 14 gender
item number nine motions on notice no
motions on notice have been received in
accordance with council procedure rule
three agenda item number ten the leaders
report would members please note that
item number ten the leaders report has
been withdrawn agenda item number 11 the
annual report please from the chairman
of the overview and scrutiny panel i
call upon councillor david saunders to
present his report Thank You chairman
and apologies in advance who members if
my voice gives out sometime during this
this report members despite there being
seven weeks until the council's annual
general meeting on the 11 from a this
evening I am presenting the 2016-17
annual report for the overview and
scrutiny panel firstly there for and
this is normally done at the annual
meeting first look there for and on
behalf of the overview and scrutiny
panel members I should like to take this
opportunity to thank offices
particularly Charles hungry for their
help and support during the past year
members that said pages 10 5 to 10 9 of
this evenings agenda pack summarizes the
key achievements of the panel during
2016-17 you will know from my previous
reports and as outlined in sections 5
and 6
of your papers new scrutiny arrangements
including public speaking we're
introduced in 2016 for a trial period
and although the take-up of new
arrangements have not been as
anticipated it is hoped that in the
spirit of transparency the reason that
they are introduced that they will be
fully adopted and retained well the way
she's giving out so I commend the report
to members and I'm happy if I can to
answer any questions Thank you Thank You
councillor Saunders say wish to make
thank you very much agenda item number
12 annual report from the chairman of
governments and Audit Committee I call
upon Councillor John Buckley to present
his report Thank You chair can I ask met
all members to note the report this
evening outlined on page 111 agenda item
12 and the recommendations set out in
the action plan on page 124 and like
councillor saunders i'd also like to
thank all officers and members of the
committee for their sterling work during
the last 12 months thank you thank you
thank to any members wish to make any
comment councillor service thank you
very much chairman I did have notes
annotated on my agenda on Mozgov but
unfortunately died before the meeting so
please bear with me I'll try and
remember what I'd written I just like to
thank officers particularly actually for
the very clear and easy to read way the
reports are now set out for this meeting
it is really helpful and I think it's a
very positive move also I just wanted to
highlight that at our recent meeting on
the eighth of Mark it's important to
make all members aware as mr. house has
actually mentioned in the minutes that I
saw today that we actually
the council sign up to the local code of
corporate governance in fact I printed a
copy of myself because I think it's
quite important and i look forward to
mr. house making almonds of the council
aware of this i mean it's just all very
positive good stuff really but i just
think sometimes things go on at meetings
and if you're not a member of that
committee you're not always aware of it
so it is important and also like to
touch on the training for members
because i think as we all know some of
us have more Skills and others and I
certainly know that I have very few but
I always amiga to learn and so I do hope
that consideration will be given very
soon to a program for the training of
members of the governance and Audit
Committee as well as others because some
people do get moved from one committee
to another mr. chairman and so therefore
they have missed the induction turning
on that check the circuit thank you much
agenda item number 13 the annual report
the chairman of the standards committee
Lea call upon dr. sex them to present
his report dr. section please can you
make your way to the front bench
Thank You chairman and members will have
received this report and we'll have read
it I think we have nothing further to
add but I'm happy to take any questions
okay thank you to any members wish to
make any comments just remains for me
then to thank you very much dr. section
for your service and always Lloyd
Sherman thank you thank you seeing the
policy statement for the financial year
2017-18 i call upon counselor wealth
creation Thank You Sharon the how you
policy statement sets out with counsel
approach to pain according to 68 section
38 of our localism ACT 2011 the purpose
is to ensure transparency regarding the
counsel approach to the setting of
employee pay the paper represents the
pay policy statements for financial year
2017-18 and must by law we approved by
resolution is counsel before 31st March
2017 the statement simply sets those
policies and documents which are
relevant to pay and remuneration for
employees of this council I move the
recommendation as contained in the
report thank you is there a second to
please I council ferb off thank you and
you members have any comments they wish
to make in that case do members agree
thank you very much gender item number
15 the Community Safety Partnership plan
for twenty seventeen to twenty twenty i
call upon counselors in febrile Thank
You chairman every year our community
safety team coordinates the drafting of
the planet Community Safety Partnership
plan this year is no difference and I am
pleased to present this year's draft
plan the Community Safety Partnership
consists of a number of statutory
agencies including health Kent Fire
Rescue and Kent Police datasets from all
the key agencies are analyzed to
establish the key areas the
the ship should focus on last year's
action plan resulted in 441 joint
antisocial behavior investigations these
included for criminal behavior orders 5
civil injunctions two premises closures
5 community protection notices and 58
community protection warning notices in
addition the partnership organised 61
Community Payback reparation events and
these included painting work litter
sweeps and graffiti removals in addition
to the benefit of these events from a
justice perspective they have saved
other agencies from picking up these
costs the team also facilitated the
support of 64 prolific offender
offenders to foster rehabilitation and
established a bespoke mental health peer
support group which is now supporting
other ex-service users finally the
partnership enabled over 500 children to
visit the Kent Safety Center and
undertook 436 home safety visits as you
can see it's been a busy and productive
year and there are the work streams
which will continue into 2017-18 in
December a practitioner event was held
where good practice and ideas for next
year's in action plan were exchanged a
public engagement events and survey were
also carried out during January to
understand the areas of concern that
local residents had as the priority
areas for Senate do not alter greatly
the partnership believes that it would
be more advantageous to have a longer
term plan with actions reviewed yearly
rather than starting from scratch each
year therefore this year the team has
developed a three-year overarching plan
the summit Community Safety Partnership
executive group has agreed the plan and
the overview and scrutiny panel has been
part of the engagement process process
the overview and scrutiny panel held a
healthy discussion with robust
questioning and their feedback has been
incorporated furthermore cabinets
recommended that the planet Community
Safety Partnership approved the draft
plan on the night of March 2017 I
therefore recommend
that council approves the tannic
community safety plan for 2017 to 2020
thank you thank you is there a second to
please second the reserve the right
position yes thank you Jer just to
inform members that at the Working Party
community psyche working party the
excellent officer counter-culture
external services 'biue gave a
presentation on the antisocial behavior
new tools and enforcement powers without
let new now they've been in place for
two years now oilers the administration
and chief executive to actually include
this presentation as a members briefing
it's very soon as soon as possible and
also urge all members to attend you'll
find it extremely enlightening and there
are certain powers in there that you can
take back when you and your residents
perhaps could enact so when we do have
that briefly others many members to
attain you'll find it's one of the few
briefings that you'll probably find very
interesting and very enlightening thank
you very much Thank You counselor candle
are there any other comments from
members please cancel candle I believe
that there is a presentation being a
Range Rovers in scrutiny and it has been
suggested that we do have our members
briefing on it as well which I think
would be very informative flexibility
and gift after all did you have any
comments you want to make though thank
you very much members and members of the
public and press thank you very much for
attending that concludes the business
for this meeting of the council